Wet a one inch flat brush with yellow and orange paint...
...and sweep it in an arc above the eyebrows.
Fill in the yellow.
Wet a brush and load it with black paint.
Starting with the longer tip of the brush down...
...paint a line from right between the eyebrows arching  up to the right side.
Repeat on the opposite side.
It's ok to cover some of the sunset.
Right above the eyebrows with a shorter end of the brush leading...
...sweep a curved line around the eye ending in a point on the cheek.
Next, draw an upside down triangle on the nose.
Make the outside part of the bat wing.
And fill in with black.
Make a vertical line slightly to the left of center of the sunset.
Sweep the brush down and then back up.
Fill the bottom part in with black.
Take a small round brush and edge the sunset with black.
Leave a little gap for a starburst.
For finishing touches you can take a liner brush...
...and make some little accents.